[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back everybody throughout the
hour we've explored how music could
shape the pursuit of equality across
this country our next guests are all
about promoting harmony with their
multi-genre Acappella vocals now
performing I wish I knew how it would
feel to be free give it up for King's
[Applause]
return I wish I knew how it would feel
to be free I wish I could break all the
chains holding me oh I wish I could say
all the things that I should say say
loud say clear for the whole round world
to hear I wish I could share all the
love in my heart remove all the words
that keep us
how I wish you could know what it means
to be me you see and age how it feels to
be free you'll see ande how it feel to
be
free and how it feels to be
free I wish I could give all I'm longing
to give oh I wish
I could live like I'm long to oh I wish
I could do all the things that I can do
throw away throw them away overdo overdo
I'll starting a new I wish I could be
like a bird in the Sky Sweet how sweet
it would be if I found I could fly I
sore to the side I like down at the sea
i s cuz I know how it feel to be you'll
see andree how it feels to be
free you'll see and how it feels to be
free you
see it
feel you'll see and agree how it feels
to be
you see
ande how it feel to be free sing because
I know what it feels like to be
free see cuz I know just how it feels to
[Music]
be all right once more put your hands
together for Te turn everybody we latest
out4 pick it up wherever you get your
music we be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home